[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 l'hebdo la
dernière de la saison voici les titres
de ce vendredi 7 juillet la ministre des
armées en déplacement à satory françoise
paris s'est rendu sur le site versailles
et pour échanger avec les militaires sur
place évaluer la qualité de leurs
équipements
c'est son premier déplacement dans les
yvelines vincent couronne est notre
invité fil rouge pour cette émission
seyant chercheur en droit public à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines
nous reviendrons avec lui sur cette
année électorale qui semble avoir
profondément modifié le paysage
politique français
enfin dans le reste de l'actualité
locale retour sur le congrès évidemment
à versailles lundi et le séminaire
organisé mercredi à la préfecture de
versailles au tour des médias et des
quartiers prioritaires
je vous le disais en titre la nouvelle
ministre des armées
françoise paris a rendu visite ce jeudi
6 juillet aux soldats de l'armée de
terre à la section technique de
versailles à satory découverte des
équipements des futurs véhicules aussi
au programme
et puis des moments d'échangés avec des
soldats revenus d'opérations extérieures
reportage de nicolas dans driver contre
d'opération
revue des troupes pour la nouvelle
ministre des armées florence parly en
visite à la section technique de satory
elle a rencontré des militaires rentrés
du mali du proche orient ou d'autres
opérations extérieures hélicoptères
tigre lance-roquettes drones de
reconnaissance
plusieurs outils et véhicules ont été
présentés
c'est à la fois comme on dire une
pédagogie technique sur l'ensemble des
moyens dont disposent d'armes et air
mais aussi un échange avec des soldats
qui ont vécu des épreuves et qui sont
les mieux à même au fond de commenter
les avantages et des inconvénients des
équipements qu'on leur confie les moyens
dont ils disposent doivent être
proportionnées au niveau d'engagement
parce que nous avons le devoir la
responsabilité d'être efficace est de
protéger nos soldats
le budget défense représente en 2010 est
plus de 37 milliards d'euros dont 8,6
milliards alloués à l'armée de terre ce
qui permet de financer de nouveaux
projets le programme scorpion c'est du
renouvellement de véhicules
c'est du renouvellement de systèmes
d'information et de commandement
et puis c'est aussi de la simulation
pour l'entraînement et pour faire
évoluer les procédés de combat les
besoins des militaires et des programmes
d'armement sont suivis ici à la section
technique de satory sous la direction du
général à rémy fouillant les tests
autour du programme scorpion devrait se
poursuivre les véhicules devrait être
opérationnel en 2018 et durant sa visite
la ministre s'est aussi exprimé sur les
conditions de logement des militaires
sur le site versailles et françois de
mazières le maire de la ville l'avait
interpellé un peu plus tôt sur le sujet
écouter la réponse de françoise par lee
nous avons évoqué cette question avec le
maire de versailles en présence du staff
agenais
administration du ministère et nous
allons en effet regardez ce que nous
pouvons faire car
en effet les conditions de logement que
je n'ai pas vu moi même mais qui n'ont
été décrites ne sont pas ne sont pas
correct ni acceptable par rapport aux
standards ou non peut attendre en ce
début de xxième siècle d
confort dans des logements qui en région
parisienne et la présence d'une ministre
dans les yvelines nous permet de faire
la transition ou politique avec notre
invité fil rouge de ce vendredi vincent
couronne bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
enseignant chercheur à l'université de
versailles saint-quentin-en-yvelines
spécialisé en droit public
on va revenir avec vous un petit peu sur
cette année politique qui semble je le
disait avoir tout chambouler aussi on
revient un an en arrière la victoire
semblait promise à alain juppé à
l'époque est à la droite celui-ci
finalement on n'a même pas passé l'étape
des primaires ajoute aussi hollande
valls sarkozy fillon et puis tant
d'autres et un presque inconnu j'ai
envie de dire de 39 ans en politique
depuis trois ans seulement emmanuel
macron est devenu président de la
république et qui plus est sans se
définir de droite ou de gauche
est ce que on pouvait même une seconde
imaginer un tel scénario
concrètement selon vous je pense que
pour nom est difficile d'imaginer un
scénario avant l'élection définitive et
je crois que les élections précédentes
l'ont montré aussi si on regarde
l'élection de jacques chirac en 95
tout le monde pensait que balladur et
l'emporter souvenons nous aussi du coup
de tonnerre dsk de dominique strauss
kahn arrêté à new york et au final alors
qu'on croyait tout ce qu'ils les lettres
et du finalement on verra dans le temps
si c'était vraiment historique cette
élection finalement sur le nom du
vainqueur
comment dire on a toujours des surprises
ont très souvent des surprises donc
c'est pas vraiment la nouveauté la
nouveauté ici c'est le renouvellement
des députés à l'assemblée nationale
c'est la jeunesse du président de
république et c'est effectivement le
fait qu'ils se revendiquer de gauche et
de droite
alors on verra s'il fait même si à
l'époque il y avait aussi plus ou moins
valéry giscard d'estaing alors qu'il
était de centre droite mais le centre a
déjà été au pouvoir en france là aussi
on pourrait s'interroger sur cette
valeur du rhône au 8 août a fait alors
là après c'est plus du commentaire
politique inquiets - de mon ressort mais
valéry giscard d'estaing était ancré au
centre droit était soutenu par la droite
glassman cas là où sont les rock
questionnement on sait pas si macro et
en marchant vocation à remplacer le
parti socialiste ou plutôt à
concurrencer la droite
c'est pas forcément très claire
aujourd'hui alors même si vous n'êtes
pas un spécialiste pur et dur de ces
questions politiques là on dit aussi que
on a condamné le parti socialiste les
républicains ils sont bons on dit ou
surtout en tout cas le parti socialiste
est ce que là aussi c'est pas aller trop
vite en besogne et finalement il
faudrait prendre un peu le temps de voir
concrètement si si c'est le cas ou pas
en politique c'est très difficile de
faire des prévisions donc mon avis va
c'est les commentateurs à chaque fois
qui peut-être font monter les choses les
médias qui n'y portent un regard un peu
trop pressant sur les exactement
imaginer un échec politique d' emmanuel
macron au terme de son quinquennat
on peut très bien imaginer un échec
d'ailleurs sur des mesures plutôt
libérale ou de droite on peut très bien
imaginer le parti socialiste repartir je
veux dire avec un nombre de députés un
élu peut-être même à l'elysée tout est
possible en 2020 2022 d'autant plus
qu'on ne sait pas qui va remplacer jean
christophe cambadélis au parti
socialiste
sk des nouvelles figures qui vont
émerger en mesures éventuellement de de
prendre un vrai leadership tout est
possible tout aussi bien le ps peut
disparaître alors en tant que chercheur
est forcément regarder et puis vous
étiez aussi le fondateur vous êtes
toujours le fondateur du site les
surligneurs vous allez regarder cette
campagne de près une réflexion sur ces
aussi ses commentaires sur un peu ce
président de la république aurait eu
toutes les planètes alignés pour lui le
fn qui fait une pas si bonne campagne
que ça le ps et qui implosent les
républicains qui se déchire la sphère
fillon toutes ces choses là on selon les
commentateurs aussi joué favorablement
pour emmanuel macron est-ce que selon
vous les français ont voté parce que
emmanuel macron offrez une politique
intéressante selon eux ou surtout parce
que finalement autour de lui tout s'est
écroulé
tout s'est écroulé mais c'est peut-être
aussi un peu de leur faute donc macro et
il sans conteste à profiter de ça mais
si on regarde élection de françois
hollande on dit souvent qu'il a été lui
aussi contre sarkozy on dit que nicolas
sarkozy a été élu aussi contre
l'immobilisme de jacques chirac et ses
bons et contre ségolène royal qui était
sa concurrente en 2007
donc on est souvent élus plutôt contre
ses concurrents et l'affaiblir et ses
concurrents que pour ses propres
qualités il ya qu'à voir le fait qu'au
premier tour un candidat quel qu'il soit
la présidentielle fait 25 30% grand
maximum et tout le second tour il est
élu en réalité le présent et public
seule une minorité de gens à la base le
soutiennent véritablement aujourd'hui
une question se pose aussi par rapport à
peut-être à l'opposition selon vous et
puis on passera après aux questions
peut-être plus en rapport avec le droit
mais quelle est la vraie opposition m de
mac ronde s'est pas vraiment si ce sont
les républicains nouvelle gauche donc
anciennement les socialistes à
l'assemblée nationale la france
insoumise le fn ça aussi on est un peu
perdu est ce qu'on peut savoir
aujourd'hui qu'il incarne le mieux cette
opposition où il faudra attendre aussi
il je crois qu'il va falloir attendre
pour moment ce qu'on peut voir d'un
point de vue strictement institutionnels
sait compter les votes pour et contre
l'investiture du gouvernement serbe a
priori ceux qui ont voté contre
l'investiture du gouvernement philippe
sont dans l'opposition etc voilà
s'éparpille essentiellement entre la
france insoumise dans une moindre mesure
et dans une partie dans une mesure plus
importante
au sein des républicains dia beaucoup
plus de députés d'ailleurs même si la
france a soumises fait beaucoup de bruit
notamment avec son leader médiatique 17
députés c'est peut-être un peu léger
pour représenter l'opposition
principalement il savait toute la
difficulté de l'opposition c'est à dire
déjà identifié on a un parti plus ou
moins importants minoritaires qu'est que
sont les républicains mais qui sont une
opposition douce a priori ou qui ont
l'intention d'être une opposition plutôt
douce et la france insoumise qui est un
tout petit groupe 17 députés à
l'assemblée nationale et qui en réalité
seront probablement une opposition
beaucoup plus dur mais je crois que si
la france insoumise se positionne en
tant qu'opposition dur c'est aussi parce
que justement ils sont peu nombreux
donc qu'est les outils leur reste-t-il
pour pouvoir protester c'est venir à
l'assemblée nationale sans cravate ne
pas venir au congrès etc
faire faire du buzz vous parliez du
concret je voulais je voulais vous en
parlez aussi puis sur ceux sur ce
renouveau on a souvent dit qu'il manuel
mâcon son offre politique sa personne
aussi faisait référence à au renouveau
c'est ce qu'on lit et on entend partout
mais finalement quand on voit ses
premiers pas de la république j'ai
presque envie de dire qu'il a moins de
renouveau que les derniers ses
prédécesseurs nicolas sarkozy et
françois hollande lui incarne vraiment
le président entre guillemets à
l'ancienne le chef qui est un peu au
dessus de la mêlée qui a une pensée un
peu complexe oui pour jeu fort plaisante
avec les médias oui exactement c'est à
dire que alors qu'on présente la
jeunesse des mannequins de macron le
renouveau à l'assemblée nationale comme
des choses qu'ils ont
qui sont plutôt de nature à renouveler
complètement le paysage politique et les
idées en réalité dans la pratique du
pouvoir
c'est une pratique qui est purement
gaulliste ou comment dire golo
mitterrandienne éventuellement mais
c'est essentiellement gaulliste d'abord
le fait que le présent à public se
positionne déjà et de gauche et de
droite ni de gauche de droite c'est un
peu la même chose
c'est très gaulliste se placer au dessus
des partis
le fait comme cela aussi d'avoir tout un
nombre de députés tout tout neuf qui
rentre à l'assemblée nationale et qui
vous soutiennent ça ça rappelle
élections de 1962 les élections
déchetterie bout de gaulle a vu ses
partisans ont créé en mars l'assemblée
nationale tout nouveau bon donc en
réalité on est dans une situation qui
est la cinquième des débuts pourquoi pas
en réalité on revient vraiment
aux origines du texte aux origines la
pratique de la cinquième en tout cas
qu'il soit adoubé comme critique
emmanuel macron et puis son premier
ministre edouard philippe met en place
progressivement lors leur politique en
tout cas ils dévoilent leur carte ils
ont dévoilé leurs cartes cette semaine
et un volet justice a été évoquée par
edouard philippe devant les députés
il y aura désormais c'est un peu
l'annoncent principal pour le monde de
la justice
une loi de programmation des moyens sur
cinq ans est ce que c'est une bonne
nouvelle selon vous ça ne peut être
qu'une bonne nouvelle après une loi de
programmation dont engage à rien ça sert
à quoi concrètement qu'est-ce que ça
pourquoi c'est une bonne nouvelle
alors c'est une bonne nouvelle parce que
il semblerait et dans le discours de
politique générale du premier ministre
que la justice soit mise ou dans l'un
des premiers rangs des premières
priorités du gouvernement c'est très
bien parce que la justice est sous-doté
sous développés il ya un vrai problème
en france par rapport aux autres
démocraties occidentales de la place et
des moyens de la justice
on peut comprendre la frustration de la
police lorsqu'elle a enquêté qu'elle
arrête et que derrière elle voit en elle
un tank et pas forcément jugé à la
hauteur de ce qu'il faudrait suu kyi
relâcher ou qui ne peut pas comment dire
effectuer une peine dignement ou non les
mesures derrière de peine les mesures de
pelles sont une injustice en réalité
tente sous dotées elle ne peut pas en
réalité faire le travail de continuation
du travail de la police donc ça c'est un
vrai problème
en quoi c'est une bonne nouvelle mais
comme un début de bonne nouvelle c'est
que la programmation dont gages à rien
d'avoir une autre programmation c'est
une loi qui est adoptée sur plusieurs
années
450 places en cinq ans ça serait cinq
ans la durée du quinquennat on a vu ça
déjà sûr avec la loi de programmation
militaire c'est-à-dire qu'on programme
un budget sur cinq années
sauf que d'abord cette fois
programmation d'après la constitution
elle n'est pas obligatoire c'est à dire
que n'a pas de force obligatoire les
projets la respecter et en plus de ça
chaque année on peut la réviser à la
baisse à la hausse
c'est ce qu'on a fait avec les armes et
françois hollande après les attentats
avait révisé à la hausse le budget des
armées
voilà là on pourrait aussi s'engager
puis finalement
parce que la contrainte budgétaire est
plus compliqué que prévu on va pas
exactement obligé de la justice et donc
sans langage à rien en réalité c'est
simplement de la communication politique
mais qui peut permettre aussi de montrer
un cap
vous qui connaissez mieux le monde
judiciaire que nous s'il y avait
aujourd'hui une priorité on dépeint
souvent à un constat assez alarmant du
monde de la justice pas assez de moyens
humains matériels
à vous écouter aussi on n'a pas
l'impression d'avoir une justice digne
d'une cinquième puissance économique
mondiale
quelle est la priorité ou les priorités
si vous deviez ont ciblé une je dirais
que c'est le recrutement magistrat alors
il ya un effort qui avait été fait
lorsque christiane taubira était garde
des sceaux un effort encore
supplémentaires qui avait été fait lors
de leur sommet avec le dernier garde des
sceaux qui avait réussi à arracher une
hausse du budget la justice de 5%
mais il faut bien voir que les délais
d'attentes pour les jugements sont
tellement longues dans certains
tribunaux comme je pense au tribunal de
bobigny par exemple que on a une justice
qui devient très inefficace de ce fait
ça c'est sur la question du des
ressources humaines du recrutement des
magistrats il en faut plus c'est
indéniable mais il ya autre chose aussi
il faut se rendre compte que au tribunal
par exemple de de grande instance de
paris
il y à un moment donné un moment donné
dans l'année vers l'automne où on arrête
tout simplement d'imprimer alors je vais
vous poser la question de laisser brest
s'est jamais vous dirai ce que c'est une
légende ou pas est-ce qu'on peut plus
imprimer ce que le
le juge ou l'avocat doit lui-même acheté
son stylo son crayon sont et c'est pas
eu des gens c'est vraiment ça
effectivement il ya plus d'argent dans
les caisses pour faire fonctionner le
tribunal la dernière question sur une
proposition d'edouard philippe une
révision et emmanuel macron puisque une
révision de la constitution pour
renforcer l'indépendance des magistrats
est essentielle aussi ça aujourd'hui
absolument essentiel à se dire
qu'aujourd'hui la justice n'est pas
enfin en tout cas les magistrats ne sont
pas totalement indépendant en france il
ya il ya de la neige
françois fillon g seulement en fait il
ya deux choses il ya les magistrats du
siège ceux qui vont prononcer la
sanction
ceux là sont complètement indépendants
il n'y a pas de problème la france est
en accord avec les standards
internationaux de droits de l'homme
d'indépendance à la justice par contre
il ya aussi de ce qu'on appelle les
magistrats du parquet ce qu'on appelle
la magistrature debout ce sont ces
magistrats qui est dans un tribunal vont
requérir une belle ils vont ce sont les
par exemple les procureurs cela ne sont
pas ceux qui prononce la peine mais sont
ceux qui parfois où les enquêtes mettent
en examen et ainsi de suite
et donc ce parc est là lui manque
d'indépendance
il a une forme de dépenses mais
clairement pas suffisante il faut
arriver l'indépendance totale de ce parc
et pour éviter des soupçons comme
cependant la sphère fillon ou fillon
accusé le pouvoir en place de diriger le
parquet contre lui vincent couronne
rester avec nous parce que tout de suite
à l'actualité de la semaine
et on en parlait il ya quelques minutes
cette semaine a été marquée par la tenue
du congrès lundi à versailles les
sénateurs et députés étaient réunis pour
la première fois sous la présidence d
manueel macro qui souhaitent répéter
l'exercice chaque année les elvinois
étaient évidemment présents pour ce
rendez vous sur leurs terres être
d'élections reportage avec ses images de
patrick jacques de dixmude
ils étaient près de 900 parlementaires
réunis à versailles pour écouter le
président de la république fixer le cap
de son quinquennat
parmi eux 18 représenter le département
des yvelines pour les 12 députés
fraîchement élus lors des élections
législatives
ce congrès était une première marquée
par l'importance du moment et le poids
des responsabilités
une solennité particulière évidemment
d'être à versailles ont d'ailleurs
l'ensemble de la représentation
nationale qui est ici nous c'est un
endroit particulier cet engagement que
le président avait pris et qu'il met en
place aujourd'hui devenir une fois par
an devant l'ensemble des parlementaires
non seulement dit quinn et la vision et
le cap pour l'année à venir mais
également faire l'évaluation de son
analyse va de l'analyse politique il a
proposé et des lois qui ont été mis en
place et tu est une excellente idée si
la forme a conquis les nouveaux députés
de la république en marche le fond lui a
divisé les parlementaires des
parlementaires visés directement par
quelques-unes des propositions des
manuels macron avec par exemple la
réduction de leur nombre d'un tiers ou
encore l'instauration d'une dose de
proportionnelle pour les prochaines
élections législatives
la difficulté constitutionnel qu'il ya
dans le bel la baisse du nombre
sénateurs et députés c'est la bonne
représentation est le fait des
territoires ruraux des territoires il ya
moins de monde et le fait que le député
puisse faire son travail dans des temps
qu'ils soient raisonnables au restant
bien le l'image de la diversité de nos
territoires donc ça c'est la première
éléments la proportionnelle je suis pas
une fan du tout parce qu'on a souvent
des effets d'appareils derrière le
paquet de réformes institutionnelles
sera voté d'ici un an selon le souhait
du président de la république et devrait
donc être actées lors du congrès épisode
2 prévue l'an prochain
vincent couronne emmanuel macron qui
souhaite convoquer le congrès tous les
ans un peu à l'image de l'état de
l'union de ce qui se fait aux etats-unis
c'est une bonne nouvelle selon vous
c'est une bonne chose ou alors c'est un
peu une américanisation néfaste pour la
vie politique français c'est ce que
certains disent
disons que c'est une bonne chose si
comment dire politiquement c'est un
engagement du présent la république qui
souhaite le faire donnons lui la
possibilité ou laissons le faire pour
voir ce que ça donne après c'est pas
forcément une américanisation parce que
un tel discours quand responsables
politiques chef de l'état vienne
s'exprimer devant un parlement
y'a rien de bourran qualité à ça parce
qu'avant que le président puisse venir
s'exprimer devant le parlement
il avait la possibilité d'envoyer des
messages tous les présents d'un
cinquième l'ont fait tous au lendemain
d'ailleurs des élections et puis c'est
un comment dire c'est une prérogative
traditionnelle d'un responsable
politique
il y a effectivement le discours sur
l'état de l'union qui est peut-être plus
connus aux etats-unis où le président
américain chaque année entre congrès est
reçu par les parlementaires et comment
son discours chaque année mais au
royaume uni la reine d'angleterre fait
la même chose chaque année elle a fait
un discours du trône ya quelques
semaines à peine où elle a eu avec un
chapeau très remarqué d'ailleurs mais
c'est aussi la même chose en chef d'état
qui est reçu en grande pompe devant le
parlement pour ce pur pour expliquer sa
politique
voilà donc s'il ya rien de commander
c'est vraiment un pouvoir traditionnel
d'un responsable politique et c'est pas
normal qu'en france on le fasse aussi un
mot pour terminer maintenant sur eux sur
les surligneurs le site internet que
vous avez lancé cette année pour la
campagne présidentielle et qui vérifie
la légalité des propositions des hommes
et femmes politiques laventure va se
poursuivre à la rentrée ou alors c'était
uniquement pour cette campagne
électorale laventure va se poursuivre
évidemment parce qu'il ya du travail
alors surtout avec beaucoup de nouveaux
députés qui effectivement apprennent un
petit peu la politique sur le tas et
puis évidemment les erreurs juridiques
dans le discours des politiques
il est omniprésent donc on va continuer
et même plus encore demain que hier vous
avez beaucoup de travail qui vous attend
si j'ai bien compris merci beaucoup
travaillent merci vincent couronne pour
votre venue en plateau je rappelle que
vous êtes enseignant chercheur à
l'ubuesque hui et donc fondateur du site
les surligneurs merci à vous et puis bel
été l'actualité de cette semaine marquée
aussi par l'hommage national mercredi
pour les obsèques de simone veil la
femme politique est rescapé de la shoah
reposera avec son époux au panthéon
celle annonces du président de la
république fait mercredi lors de son
éloge funèbre
celles qui restent avant tout dans
l'esprit des français pour avoir
légalisé l'avortement en 1975 en tant
que ministre a aussi donné son nom à la
faculté de médecine de saint quentin en
yvelines
elle était d'ailleurs venu sur place le
3 décembre 2012
et cette semaine nous sommes allez vous
demander ce que représentait pour vous
simone veil écouter ses réponses au
micro de patrick jacques de dixmude une
belle femme entre guillemets sur tous
les plans qui a apporté beaucoup
beaucoup de choses à nous les femmes des
jeux serrés caïds et les fameux pour
l'avortement sans erreurs on n'aurait
pas pu donc voilà c'est un bon signal
nous a donné un bouquet deux femmes une
femme en tant que femme est une femme
politique extraordinaire comme on en
fait comme il y en a plus aujourd'hui
quoi honnêtes intègres profondément
humaine une femme de caractère qui
prenait les choses à bras le corps
une vrai visionnaire est quelqu'un de
très courageux
voilà était fidèle à ses convictions qui
a su s'imposer devant d une situation
difficile j'ai une grande admiration
[Musique]
mercredi toujours alors que les lycéens
découvrez le résultat du bac les parents
d'élèves et les professeurs des collèges
protester eux à guyancourt contre les
ajustements de dotation mise en place
par la direction et des services
départementaux de l'éducation nationale
est des ajustements qui touche les
établissements des yvelines et qui nuit
selon eux à leur fonctionnement
elle les précisions avec ce sujet
d'haussmann vendeurs d à l'appel du
syndicat snes 78 ils sont une vingtaine
devant les locaux de la direction des
services départementaux de l'éducation
nationale par mieux des professeurs et
des parents d'élèves qui protestent
contre les ajustements de dotation dans
les établissements des yvelines
aujourd'hui on se rassemble dans le
cadre des ajustements de dotation
horaire c'est à dire c'est le nombre
d'heures d'enseignement qui sont
attribués à chaque établissement pour
protester contre des ajustements qui ont
été faits par la direction académique
des yvelines et qui conduisent en fait à
tout simplement reprendre des moyens
certains établissements pour les
attribuer à d'autres
alors que les projets les dispositifs
dead sont mis en place et qui sont remis
en cause par ces ajustements selon le
syndicat les conséquences sont lourdes
pour les établissements comme des
projets qui ne peuvent plus être financé
des dispositifs dead qui disparaissent
ont encore des postes fragilisé à cause
du sureffectif des classes à la rentrée
prochaine certaines classes de 6e pour
être composée de 32 élèves
oui les élèves en pâtissent ne serait ce
que parce que pour pouvoir les
accueillir sereinement en septembre il
faut avoir préparé le travail en amont
est que si le travail qui a été préparé
et des faits au mois de juillet
évidemment nous inquiète pas dans
d'aussi bonnes conditions si vous avez
prévu de suivre une classe de 5e avec
des petits groupes tout au long de
l'année et qu'on vous annonce qu'en fait
vous allez être deux professeurs sur une
même classe sans dédoublement ce ne sont
pas du tout les mêmes conditions
d'accueil l'inspection académique
pas souhaité s'exprimer sur le sujet le
snes 78 espèrent être reçus dans les
prochaines semaines par les services
départementaux de l'éducation nationale
engager le dialogue entre journalistes
et acteurs des quartiers priorité à
c'était l'objectif d'un séminaire
organisé mardi à la préfecture des
yvelines des journalistes de france
télévisions ont animé une après midi
d'échangés à laquelle ont participé près
de 250 personnes
reportage de camille lambert fabriquer
un journal éviter l'effet que muse et
mener une enquête
voilà les thématiques abordées tout
l'après-midi un séminaire pour favoriser
le dialogue entre acteurs de
l'information et habitants des quartiers
prioritaires
chaque mot vous dites besoin est
important
le lien était dégradée parce que ça ne
valorise pas les habitants que de
toujours voir au journal télévision
télévisée des barres d'immeubles des
voitures qui brûlent des poubelles qui
brûlent des violences urbaines
donc il fallait vraiment que les
habitants des quartiers les
professionnels soit face aux
journalistes et qu'ils se parlent
doivent être conscients qu'ils sont
porteurs d'un message qui peut
dévastateur ou très bénéfique
et si on ne fait pas attention mais on
peut catapulter une commune par exemple
quand de la mienne
quinze ans en arrière retrouver une
confiance mutuelle par un échange
sincère 250 élus policiers éducateurs et
travailleurs sociaux ont participé à
cette conférence animée par des
journalistes de france télévisions pour
le rédacteur en chef du magazine
denquête de france deux caches
investigations plus d'événements de ce
type devraient avoir lieu
et une très grande défiance vis-à-vis du
travail des journalistes et vis-à-vis de
l'information en général je crois que
voilà le seul moyen de sortir cette
défiance et devenir de s'expliquer
l'éducation à l'image l'éducation à
l'info doit faire partie de ce qu'on
apprend de ce qu'on apprend dans l'est
dans les écoles c'est important parce
que ça fait partie de la vie ce
partenariat entre france télévisions et
la préfecture des yvelines a été mis en
place en début d'année 2010 est il a
permis de réaliser différentes actions
d'éducation aux médias
c'est la fin de ce set 8 l'hebdo merci
de nous avoir suivis retrouver tous nos
reportages en replay sur tv 78 points
comme ou l'application tv 78 bon ok là
tout ce bel été à tous et rendez vous à
la rentrée
[Musique]
pour
e